some of the best-known characters in the
comics universe
Captain America The Incredible Hulk the
Mighty Thor Iron Man even spider-man
were co-created by the king of comics
Jack Kirby but Kirby never owned the
copyright to the characters he drew his
employer does that's marvel many of
Kirby's most famous characters debuted
between 1958 and 1963 when artists had
little bargaining power but then
Congress passed a law in 1976 allowing
creators to reclaim the rights to their
work after a period of time Kirby died
in 1994 but now his family is suing to
get the copyright to his Marvel
characters under Congress's 1976 law
what's at stake money potentially a lot
of it Disney acquired Marvel in 2009 for
four billion dollars and in the deal got
the rights to all those Kirby characters
this led to movies like The Avengers and
sequels to Iron Man Thor Captain America
collectively these movies made more than
four billion more dollars at the box
office alone two lower courts have
already sided with Marvel the Kirby
estate has asked the Supreme Court to
hear their case it hinges on something
called a work made for hire the
copyright in a work belongs to the
author who created it however if a work
is made for hire the employer in this
case Marvel is considered the author not
the employee who created the work Jack
Kirby the Kirby's contend that they have
the right to terminate Marvel's
copyright because of Congress's 1976 law
the court should decide whether or not
to take the case in September if the
court takes the case and rules in the
Kirby's favor the family could be
entitled to some of those superhero
Billy's